good morning heck it's tuesday and i
have a question um should we rumble
we've been brothers for 41 years and
most of our relationship has been
aggressively non-violent like when we
disagree which is not often we usually
don't even raise our voices let alone
resort to fisticuffs but there was just
this youtube boxing exhibition where a
bunch of youtubers boxed each other and
like it generated quite a lot of revenue
even though the quality of the actual
boxing was and i want to put this gently
sub professional now looking i'm like 99
sure it's a terrible idea for you and me
to box each other in a ring for a public
spectacle that raises money to build
stronger health care systems and
impoverished communities but there's
like
one percent of me that's like is it
merely a bad idea or is it a bad million
dollar idea now i suppose i should
confess that the only reason i'm even
considering this is because i'm pretty
sure i would win like as a boxer i have
two major qualifications one while i
have very little experience with
actually like throwing punches i did for
many years review books about boxing for
book list magazine so i've read like
over a hundred books about boxing and as
any of the school administrators who've
recently banned my books can tell you
reading about something makes you both
want to do it and good at it so hank i
think you and i probably have like
similar overall boxing skills but i can
say things like switch to southpaw and
jab jab hook and being able to say those
things is basically you know basically
being able to do them secondly i am
married to a boxer when sarah and i met
she was a very competitive boxer and i
feel like she could train me on the
other hand when i told her about this
she said that is the worst idea i've
ever heard and if you think i'm gonna
help you you're incorrect the other
thing that's whispering in my ear that
maybe this isn't the worst idea i've
ever had is that laboring under the
prospect of getting whooped by my
brother in front of an audience i think
would make me extremely interested in
and dedicated to personal fitness i
would have to sculpt this 44 year old
flesh sack into a chiseled fighting
machine and hank you would have to do
the same and in the process we could
potentially extend our overall health
spans provided we didn't have any
serious injuries in the ring which
frankly based on our punching power i
think is unlikely now i suppose there is
the prospect of having to actually fight
my brother in a ring in front of an
audience with the winner feeling good
and the loser feeling bad and all that
stuff which is utterly unappealing to me
i don't want you to feel bad when i tko
you one minute into the second round but
maybe you wouldn't feel sad maybe you'd
feel motivated maybe you'd come back
stronger and defeat me in the sequel
just like happens in rocky 2 retroactive
spoiler alert and then maybe millions of
people would watch the trilogy fight on
pay-per-view and we'd both be grizzled
veterans trotting out for one last title
chance just like 40-year-old bob
fitzsimmons who was known as the
freckled wonder and who in 1903
withstood a 30-round boxing match to
become the light heavyweight champion of
the world all of which i know from
reading the book lanky bob now of course
there are also reasons why this is a
terrible idea including one i don't
really want to have shirtless pictures
of us available on the internet also too
i think the public perception of us is
correctly that we like each other and a
boxing match might harm that image
furthermore three i don't know that i
want to lift up regulated violence as
the number one strategy for content
creators to grow their platform or
increase their revenue and so i think
ultimately hank it probably doesn't make
sense for us to become semi-professional
pugilists i mean we could spend the next
nine months training to box each other
or we could spend that time writing
books and making educational videos and
raising money for partners in health and
all that stuff and i think that's
probably the right call which is a real
shame because i could have been a
contender
hank i'll see you on friday